travis scott
he is that
what is he a rapper or a singer or
something i don't know again i had never
heard of him until he there was a a real
attack at his concert at astroworld
where people were killed it was
overcrowded there was all this creepy
satanic imagery everywhere including the
entrance to the concert and some of the
mottos and slogans from the concert a
lot of the imagery was satanic and then
people died and it was really really
ugly
travis scott now is facing a lot of
lawsuits about this and so he's saying
no it wasn't intentionally satanic
all that imagery no don't it's not what
you think it is i am a man of god
i am a man of god he says i don't know
if travis scott is a man of god maybe he
is maybe he isn't
isn't really for me to know that sort of
thing
i'm a little skeptical of it given all
the satanic imagery
maybe he's just saying i'm a man of god
to cover his derriere because he's about
to be ruined with all of these lawsuits
but the the only reason i mentioned this
story i don't have very much to say
about the story of astroworld in the
lawsuits the only reason i mention it
with regard to the notre dame
thing
is that i don't even want to call it a
renovation or a risk it's just a it's a
thing it's a degradation is what it is
is that travis scott is either a man of
god or a man of the devil
okay
it is binary you can't be non-binary
when it comes to religion
you're you're with god or against god
that that's in the bible that's where
george bush got that line from his
war on terror speeches we said you're
either with us or against us
well it's from the bible and it happens
to be true you're either with god or
you're against god and you you can't
really just be neutral i know that we
live in this time where we think
everything can be neutral and it comes
from
a perverted view of liberalism that was
really popular in the 20th century that
you can just be neutral on we have
neutral public schools we're gonna have
neutral public squares and we're
everything's gonna be totally neutral
news media but you can't you're gonna
have to have premises you're gonna have
to believe something and it's in the
neutrality is an illusion so pick one or
the other i certainly
certainly think it's wiser to bet on god
i would not i would not throw in your
lot with the devil i'm glad you like
that clip
i am that makes me feel good especially
this time of year christmas time
i'm happy i feel i love our whole
extended family here
if you want to get all the notifications
you got to ring that bell subscribe go
to apple podcast spotify stitch or
google play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show subscribe for free leave a five
star review
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you